The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this
is Josh and John.
They're both from
Planet Nutshell.
Josh is the founder and
John is an animator?
JOHN MCGOWAN: Yes.
PROFESSOR: And they're
going to talk today
about storyboarding and
continuing our discussion
on visual storytelling.
I'm super excited
about today's session.
It's going to be a lot
of not only lecture,
but workshopping some
of the scripts and ideas
that you guys have been
thinking about so far.
Anything else?
Oh!
Josh's background is
in creative writing.
So you can also get feedback
from him on your scripts.
And they make short
explainer videos
that engage people, not only
in diseminating information,
but entertaining them as well.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah.
So we in lot of ways do many
of the things that, I mean,
I guess directly that
you guys are working on.
So this is a good fit for
us to be talking to you.
So, yeah.
So my job is to
sort of rally all
of the people who work
at Planet Nutshell
in interesting,
creative directions.
And John is a really talented
illustrator and animator.
And he also does our
storyboard artwork.
So today, after I give a brief
little talk about animation
and storyboarding,
we'd like to just
open things up and
share with you a script
that we produced a while ago.
And we'll all
storyboard it together.
And I would love to see
what we come up with.
We've produced this
script, but what's
really great about
what we do is there's
no one right way to do it.
So what will be interesting
is to see what we
come up with collectively here.
As opposed to what we produced.
And I have looked at
your scripts, the things
that you're working on.
They're all really interesting.
So I would like
to open things up
to any questions you
have about what you're
working on a little later.
And yeah, I write
a lot of scripts.
So if you need
help with that, I'm
very willing to give
you any guidance I can.
So I'll get started with
this short lecture portion.
Somebody made this spinning
thing for you guys today.
We thought that would
be a nice touch.
Ding!
All right.
Let's see.
Yeah, so we're going
to talk about animation
and storyboarding.
And specifically, animation in
the context of what you guys
are doing.
I mean, animation
is a huge topic.
I'm not going to talk about
techniques or theory or any
of that kind of stuff.
But I do want to talk about
when it's a good idea to use it
maybe in your own work.
And there may be more
reasons why it might be good.
But these are the ones that
I came up with for today.
So animation is good when
synthesizing, reinforcing,
or recapping information
in a simple, visual way.
Cows plus farts
equals global warming.
So taking abstract ideas
or summarizing information
and presenting it very
simply is something
that animation is
really good at.
So when thinking about
developing your own scripts,
you can think about moments
where the visual story could
be augmented with some sort
of encapsulation or summary
that is worthy of animation.
And here's one that's
pretty obvious.
The subject cannot be seen,
it's microscopic, cosmic,
or theoretical and abstract.
So those are often good times
to think about animation.
And we have some examples
of where this sort of thing
is employed later.
John came up with this one.
Actually, John helped
with all these.
Because I was really
busy this week.
So I really appreciate it.
Footage is not
easily attainable.
So say you want to do a video
about-- well, in your case,
you know you're doing
navel engineering.
Maybe you want to shoot
something about, like,
the bottom of the ship.
Or something,
you're going to have
to hire a team of scuba
divers to get down there
and shoot the hull of the ship.
So that might be a nice
opportunity for visualization
that can't be attained
through live action.
And kind of the
catch-all category
is that animation adds
visual engagement.
The story is somehow
made better by using it.
And that's sort of an abstract,
subjective thing to say.
But I think the best
way to demonstrate
that is just to show examples.
Which I'll do in a bit.
So animation is sort of
silly or not a great choice--
we use this term a lot.
Like, is this eye
candy, or is this really
a functional part of the story?
Again, is it eye candy or
is the story made better?
So just using animation
because it's cool or it's neat
can actually distance the
viewer and disengage them
from the experience.
Because, I don't know if
you guys watch-- you know,
you've seen a movie
like Transformers.
Or, god, what are some of
these ridiculously visually
opulent movies, you know?
And a lot of times when I
watch those sorts of things,
I begin to emotionally
disengaged from them.
Because all I'm doing
is being bombarded
by visual information.
There's no story that's really
compelling or engaging me.
So that's something
to think about.
Live action is really great
that at a number of things.
And these are some of the
things I came up with.
The notion of personality,
the human face,
the human experience.
The host, is Elizabeth
talked about on Monday.
Location, creating--
animation can create
a lot of interesting locations.
But why would you
draw the MIT campus
when you have it right in
front of you, for instance?
And again, the notion
of human interaction.
Humans talking to each other
and engaging with each other
is something that live
action is really good at.
And the final,
catch-all category
is you just can't think
of anything better to do.
So, oh, I'm just going
to animate that part.
I don't really want
to think about how
I'm going to present this.
So I'm just going to
do some animation.
And that's not the best choice.
You should be
making choices based
on what the strengths
of animation are
and the strength of live action.
PROFESSOR: And just
to add to that,
that's also the
easiest choice to make.
And the one that
happens most often.
Or the one that
happened most often
when we were making seasons
one and two is that we'd
hit a point in the script
that looks a little bit
complex in terms of
visual execution.
And we'd say, well, what
are you going to do here?
And the host or the cast
would say, oh, well,
we're just going to animate it.
As if, like, that was going
to solve all their problems.
And I think that
these points may sound
pretty reasonable and obvious.
But it's very, very hard to
thoughtfully integrate that
into your visual script.
So I really encourage you
guys to think about especially
the third point, not
defaulting to animation
because you don't want to figure
out how to visually integrate
your script into the video.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah.
OK, so here are some examples
of videos that integrate
both live action and animation.
There are many examples.
I thought these were
especially strong ones.
I don't know what
you guys-- you're
going to talk more about
how you made this one.
But the composition
of this one works.
It was obviously
designed around position
of the live action character
and the animated elements.
Who has seen this
Story of Stuff series?
It's quite interesting.
PROFESSOR: Do you want to
play just a little of it?
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah, I'll
play a little bit of it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So next, the--
Do you have one of these?
I got a little
obsessed with mine.
In fact, I got a little
obsessed with all my stuff.
Have you ever wondered where
all the stuff we buy comes from?
And where it goes
when we throw it out?
I couldn't stop
wondering about that.
So I looked it up.
And what the textbook
said is that stuff
moves through a system.
From extraction, to
production, to distribution,
to consumption, to disposal.
All together, it's called
the materials economy.
Well, I looked into
it a little bit more.
In fact, I spent 10 years
traveling the world,
tracking where our stuff
comes from and where it goes
And you know what I found out?
That is not the whole story.
There is a lot missing
from this explanation.
For one thing, this system
looks like it's fine.
No problem!
But the truth is it's
a system in crisis.
JOSHUA GUNN: Just a
storytelling component there
that I really like is you
may already sort of know--
we talked it about on Monday.
Here's a paradigm or here's
a situation that you probably
already understand, but hang on.
There's a problem.
There's more complexity
here than you ever
could have imagined.
And I'm going to
tell you about it.
And that is a really cool
storytelling component
on top of the integration of
animation and live action.
FEMALE SPEAKER: An the reason
it's a system in crisis
is it's a linear system.
And we live on a finite planet.
And you cannot run a linear
system on a finite planet
indefinitely.
Every step along
the way, this system
is interacting with
the real world.
In real life, it's not
happening on a blank white page.
It's interacting with
societies, cultures, economies,
the environment.
And all along the way, it's
bumping up against limits.
Limits we don't see here because
the diagram is incomplete.
So let's go back through.
Let's fill in some of the
blanks and see what's missing.
Well, one of the most important
things it's missing is people.
Yes, people!
People live and work
all along this system.
And some people in this
system matter a little more
than others.
Some have a little more say.
JOSHUA GUNN: OK, so
you get the idea.
I mean, it's a long video.
But I think it retains
engagement because
of the quality of the writing.
And because of the
interest that's
created from the art work.
I encourage you to
watch the whole thing
if you get a chance.
Let's see--
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE] all
of the videos that Josh
is going to play today
are on the syllabus.
JOSHUA GUNN: Oh, OK.
Cool.
You mind if I play some of this?
Or have you guys
already seen this video?
PROFESSOR: I've got a
little clip of the portion
that I'm going to talk
about, but you can play it.
JOSHUA GUNN: OK, I'll
just play the beginning.
This has George in it, who
I assume you saw yesterday.
MALE SPEAKER: You know
what's more like life
than a box of chocolates?
Farts.
You really never know
what you're going to get.
Skunk, rotten eggs,
garbage dumpster?
The possibilities are,
unfortunately, endless.
But why do we fart?
And how does your body make
so many different smells?
The answer is fermentation.
This is a giant bioreactor.
It's also called a fermenter.
And in here, a fungus
known as brewer's yeast
is transforming water
and dead plants to beer.
So you know that thing where
you eat food and breathe
in oxygen to get your energy?
That's called respiration.
Yeast also need to
get energy from food,
but there's no oxygen
in those tanks.
So they have to use a different
process called fermentation.
Now, both your cells
and yeast cells
break food down to get energy.
But your main byproducts are
carbon dioxide and water.
And yeasts main byproducts are
carbon dioxide and alcohol.
That's how this stuff
gets to be beer.
JOSHUA GUNN: OK, I think
that-- similar concept,
the integration of
animation and live action.
And the way that the animation
somehow augments or improves
your understanding of
what he's talking about.
So let's see.
So let's switch back here.
So that's a very brief overview
of how you can use animation
in your own work.
How to do it, technically and
artistically is another matter.
I'm happy to talk
about that separately.
I don't know how
much training is
in this course for animation.
PROFESSOR: Not whole lot.
We do have the equipment
if you want to learn more.
We have about 10 of
these similar tablets
if you guys are interested
in learning about this.
But we're not going
to go super in depth.
JOSHUA GUNN: Yeah, this might
be an opportunity for you
to talk about that
segment that you did.
And from what I understand,
the animation that you do
is fairly rudimentary.
And very effective.
And it might be something that
these guys could pull off.
PROFESSOR: All
right, so I'm going
to talk a little bit
about one of the scenes
from the farts video.
This was actually
something that George
was going to talk about
yesterday in his script writing
workshop.
So this will tie
in pretty nicely
if I can get this to work.
All right, so take a second
to read this passage.
So when you were writing
the farts script,
this was a piece of information
that George had come across.
Which he found very fascinating.
It was one of the shareable
facts that he latched onto.
The fact that the microbial
population in your gut
is about 10 times greater
than all the somatic germ
cells in your body.
Now if he had said this line
in the video it would've
been a disaster, right?
But what is this passage
essentially saying?
Does anyone want
to take a guess?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Not just that.
So somatic and germ
cells basically
refers to all of
your human cells.
AUDIENCE: There's more
stuff that's not you in you
than there is pieces of you.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah basically.
AUDIENCE: Mostly [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, right.
So the way George decided
to distill this down there
10 times as many microbes
living in your gut
as there are human
cells in your body.
I mean, that's basically
what this entire passage
taken from a journal
article is saying.
But the problem with
saying just this
is that, at least for
me and for George,
one of the questions
that we thought
of as an audience
member was well,
how does that exactly work?
Like, how can you fit 10 times
as many bacteria in you, yet
you're not walking
around just oozing
bacterial cells completely
outside of your body.
Because I think a misconception
that people often have
is that they're the
same size, right?
So it was kind of this
paradox that wasn't essential
to the story of the
video to explain,
yet was a potential
point of confusion.
So this was a reason
why we decided
to use an animation in
this particular spot.
Because As Josh
was saying earlier,
we felt like the story
needed to be clarified.
We felt like the story needed
to be advanced a little bit.
But we also felt like if
we took the time to say
there are 10 times as
many microbes in your gut
as there are human
cells in your body.
Which doesn't make
sense, because you
would think that you'd
be oozing out bacteria,
but it actually is fine because
bacteria are a lot smaller
than human cells, right?
That actually is, like,
two or three seconds
of very, very
precious time wasted.
And sort of loses the
momentum of the video.
So we decided to do an animation
to explain all of that instead.
So what we did was we
had shot everything
without the animations.
And our storyboarding
process is incredibly janky.
But it essentially works.
And hopefully after
today your storyboards
will be a lot better
than the one we used.
But what I literally did was I
got the rough cut of the video.
And I got all of the footage.
And I specifically was looking
at this portion of the video
where this animation
would need to go.
And I took screenshots of the
video at various time points
where I knew the
information needed to go.
So this is setting the line
in context of the section
that he was delivering.
So the first line [INAUDIBLE]
that we carry a fermenter
right here with us in our gut.
And this was the
still that he said
that, so I was telling
the editor, at this point
I want a fermenter to show up.
And he actually motions
during the scene.
And then there was this second
line, "Except instead yeast,
my gut uses gut bacteria."
So I was trying to
convey to the editor
to take my drawing of
the yeast and swap it out
for drawing of a bacteria.
Again, this is
incredibly rudimentary.
You don't have to be an amazing
artist to pull off the clarity
that you need for a storyboard.
Then he says, "A lot of them,"
and I wanted a ton of bacteria
to show up.
And then we get to
the line, "There
are 10 times as
many gut bacteria
as there are human
cells in your body."
At which point I
wanted lots of bacteria
to show up and then show it in
comparison to the human cell.
This was going to
be the key frame
to explain the
concept of how you
can have so many bacteria
without oozing it
outside of your body.
So essentially we were
explaining the whole difference
in scale through one frame.
JOSHUA GUNN: This reminds me a
bit of the flipping cat video
we saw on Monday.
And there's a
segment in that video
that I think is kind of weak.
Where he is explaining a lot
of technical information.
I just didn't absorb it.
I couldn't follow it.
And I was thinking,
you know, this
would have been a lot better
if he'd maybe done some better
script writing.
But also maybe some
animation, you know?
I think animation can be really
good at moments like these
when you've got this
sophisticated or complex
information and you need
to maintain engagement
with the viewer.
But also encapsulate it.
Yeah, anyway, sorry to highjack.
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
That's fine. [INAUDIBLE].
And then the whole
way we wrap up
that scene is he explains
that instead of just one
species of yeast like they use
when you brew beer-- that's
the whole reason why we
were at the brewery--
my gut uses hundreds.
And if we just had
that text, I think
that it would bring up a
lot it questions or maybe
points of clarification
for the viewer
that, again, we just
didn't have the time
to explain in the script.
Which is why we relied on the
animation to do it for us.
So John's going to show
you some animations that
are awesome and very artistic.
For our animations,
I literally just
take a Sharpie and
a piece of paper,
and I draw out the doodles.
JOHN MCGOWAN: They're nice!
PROFESSOR: Thank you!
But it's nothing crazy.
And I basically scan
them in to our editor
and had named each picture.
And then in the storyboard
I had explained, OK, here's
my drawing of the fermenter.
Please refer to
fermenter.jpeg for the image
I want you to use.
And then he went into
After Effects and inverted
all of the drawings
and moved them around.
And I think you're going
to talk about After Effects
just a little bit.
JOHN MCGOWAN: We can
talk about After Effects.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And again, if you want to play
with any of this on your own,
there are really good
tutorials on Lynda.com.
And as MIT students, you
guys have free access
to the entire library.
So if you want a tutorial
on how to use After Effects,
which you all have access to
as well if you're interested.
You can just come talk
to me during class.
So we storyboarded
everything out.
And then I drew the doodles.
And the key frame
here was this picture
that sort of explains the whole
concept of how so many bacteria
can fit inside of you.
But it just takes one
picture instead of 10 words.
So this is what that scene
ended up looking like.
MALE SPEAKER: Weird.
Turns out, we all carry
a fermenter with us
right here in our gut.
Except instead of
yeast, my guy uses
bacteria, and a lot of them.
There are 10 times as many
bacteria in my intestine
as there are human
cells in my entire body.
And instead of just one
species, my gut uses--
PROFESSOR: My gut uses hundreds.
Sorry, it got cut off.
So, I mean, there are many ways
that we could have done that.
Like Josh was saying,
there's no right way
when it comes to
animations, when
it comes to video in general.
But this was sort of our
way of working around
the problem of not having access
to the footage of real bacteria
necessarily.
It was just a world that we
couldn't access, or didn't
have time to access, or would
have been too distracting
to access in this video.
The other thing I
wanted to mention really
quickly before Josh
continues is when we shot,
we shot knowing that we were
going to do the animation
overlay in mind.
You may not know
that ahead of time.
So what I would
suggest, if you're
interested in doing
something like this,
is to shoot thinking
that you're not going
to do an animation overlay.
And then just do another take.
Just in case you want to
do something like this.
So the way we
framed the shot, we
tried to make sure that the
background was dark enough
to where the animations
could appear.
This is not an ideal framing
in a not an ideal background.
So I'm sorry to use
this as an example.
This is probably one that
we could have improved.
But I'll show you another one.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
These small molecules
are called metabolites.
Just like how all the DNA in
an organism forms the genome,
all of the metabolites
form the metabolome.
Even though each metabolite can
be made from only six elements,
there are so many
possibilities that it
would take scientists
thousands of years
to make each one
and figure out--
PROFESSOR: And configure
out its usefulness.
So we had the exact same
storyboarding process
to create this.
But when we shot
Anastasia that day
I knew that this is what I
wanted to do for that scene.
So we told her to go
like this with her hand.
And we were like, we're going
to put stuff there, don't worry.
And we framed her wide enough.
And we gave her enough
grass space outside of her
that we could fit some
of these animations in.
So just anticipating
that-- and I
can talk more about
this tomorrow,
when I talk about producing--
is a good thing to do
if you want to do animations.
And I'll show you one last.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Those animals get
eaten by slightly bigger
animals, which get eaten
by slightly bigger animals.
Which get eaten by animals
at the top of the food chain.
Animals like us.
PROFESSOR: So that's the
raw footage from our video
on engineering river cleanups.
And again, this
is a spot that we
knew we wanted to do
an animation there.
So we framed her in such a way
that there is enough background
space to accommodate
for the animation.
And we actually
told her, OK, we're
going to put fish
along here in post.
So pretend like you're looking
at stuff, point to them
as if there are going be
fish there eventually.
I think we also did
it take where we just
had her delivering it normally.
So we had her framed with not
as much extra space behind her.
Just in case we weren't
going to use that animation.
But again, sort of anticipating
using that if you need.
So this is what the
final scene looked like.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Those
animals get eaten
by slightly bigger animals.
Which get eaten by
slightly bigger animals,
which get eaten by animals
at the top of the food chain.
Animals like us.
PROFESSOR: So again,
it wasn't incredibly
vital to have these animations.
One of the reasons
why we did use
it is that, in the context
of the video-- which
I'm going to show
tomorrow-- we felt
like the visual interest was
getting a little bit static.
So we used animation to
move the story forward
in that we felt like it was
getting a little visually
monotonous by the time this hit.
And the other thing is the food
web stuff is OK to explain.
I think that if you
didn't have the animation
it would still be OK.
But it just added I guess a
little moment of whimsy to it.
And so that was sort
of our justification
of putting it there.
So I just wanted to show
you guys those examples.
And Josh, you can continue on.
JOSHUA GUNN: OK!
I can switch here.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
JOSHUA GUNN: When
John is helping us
out with the
workshopping portion,
he can show you some
projects in After Effects.
I don't think After
Effects-- it's
a complex program with
a lot of capability.
But I think some
basic compositing
like this would be
quite easy in it.
So we can show you some of
those, just some basics about
After Effects.